Today, I want to discuss
how this war will end. I cannot predict
when this war will end,
but I want to make sure of certain
predictions about how
uh this war will end, okay? So, to first
understand how the war is going, let's
look at some um video clips. All right,
so this is President Donald Trump. He's
talking about the war.
It
Qatar, Saudi Arabia, UAE,
Bahrain, Kuwait,
nobody expected that. We were shocked.
And the other one, you know, they fought
back. They could have yielded. But think
of it, if we weren't around, they have
tremendous They had tremendous power.
They had thousands of missiles, most of
which we've terminated.
They had thousands of drones. They were
making drones and missiles all over the
place. We've knocked out most of those
factories. But they hit
Okay. So, what he's saying here is
we went in expecting them expecting to
hit them, kill the leadership, and then
they would surrender. We didn't expect
them to fight back. We didn't expect
them to close the Strait of Hormuz. We
didn't expect that they would hit Qatar,
Bahrain, Kuwait, okay? So, what he's
saying is we actually have a plan going
in.
And we we really didn't
think our enemies would fight back.
All right, so that This is Donald Trump.
Now, let's look at
um
his
President's preference is always peace.
There does not need to be any more death
and destruction. But if Iran fails to
accept the reality of the current
moment, if they fail to understand that
they have been defeated militarily and
will continue to be, President Trump
will ensure they are hit harder than
they have ever been hit before.
President Trump does not bluff, and he
is prepared to unleash hell.
Okay. So, what is she She This is
Caroline Leavitt, and she's the press
secretary for the White House. And what
she's saying is, "Look, we've defeated
these guys, but for whatever reason, the
Iranians don't know that."
That's the problem. The problem isn't
us. We came in with the right strategy.
We did everything right. But for
whatever reason, the Iranians, being
stupid,
don't know they've been defeated.
All right?
Never in history has a modern military
Iran had a modern military, a modern
navy, a modern air force, modern air
defenses, leadership, massive bunker.
Never has a modern military been so
rapidly and historically obliterated,
defeated from day one with overwhelming
firepower. The air campaign that we've
conducted, that Israel's conducted
alongside us, was one for the history
books, truly. And that's because we have
a president of the United States that
when he sends his war fighters out to
fight, he unties their hands to actually
go out and close with and destroy the
enemy as viciously as possible from
moment one. And that's why we see
ourselves as part of this negotiation as
well. Uh we're We We negotiate uh with
bombs. You have a choice, as we loiter
over the top of Tehran, as the president
talked about, about your future.
President has made it clear that you
will not have a nuclear weapon. The War
Department agrees. Our job is to ensure
that. And so, we're keeping our our hand
on that throttle uh as long as as hard
as is necessary to ensure the interests
of the United States of America are
achieved on Okay. So, this is Secretary
of War Peter Hoekstra, and he represents
the Pentagon, the military. And his
attitude is, "We're winning this war. We
are kicking ass,
and we don't have to negotiate because
we're kicking ass,
and we'll continue to do so." All right,
so this is the attitude of the military.
Now, um
the US media has been reporting that
Donald Trump is seeking an offer. He's
seeking negotiations.
And what Peter Hoekstra is saying is,
"No, let's negotiate with bombs, man."
Okay?
plan across the administration and a
treasury, uh we unsanctioned Russian
oil. We knew that there were about 130
million barrels on the water, and you
know, we created supply that is beyond
the Strait of Hormuz. So, we anticipated
this. We knew that the there could be a
temporary, and I want to emphasize
temporary, choke point there. And there
was 130
million barrels of floating storage. In
the coming days, uh we may unsanction
the Iranian oil that's on the water.
It's about 140 million barrels. So,
depending on how you count it, that's 10
days to 2 weeks of supply uh that the
Iranians had been pushing out. That
would have all gone to China.
In essence, we will be using the Iranian
barrels against the Iranians to keep the
price down and for the next 10 or 14
days.
Okay. So, this is the secret Secretary
of the Treasury, Scott Bessent, okay?
And he's responding to a problem, which
is
um the Americans didn't expect that the
Iranians would close off the Strait of
Hormuz.
And so, this is affecting oil supply.
And so, the global economy could be
disrupted or even destroyed if this
lasts too long. So, Scott Bessent says,
"Ha!
We knew this was going to happen, and we
have a sh- really brilliant plan to
destroy the Iranians once and for all.
Our plan is this.
We're going to let the Iranians sell
their oil and make A LOT OF MONEY,
and then they'll be destroyed."
Yeah. So, um
the Americans basically unsanctioned
Iranian oil, and because of that, the
Iranians were
were able to make $14 billion
just like that.
The total Iranian military budget
for 1 year is
$10 billion. Okay?
Okay?
So, this is American genius at work.
They knew this is what was was
happening. They knew the Iranians wanted
to destroy the global economy. So, the
Americans are like, "We're going to make
them rich so they can't destroy the
global economy. We got them now."
All right.
or and yet Iran remains a threat, a
threat to trade, a threat to the
to the Strait of Hormuz. Then I would
argue that we could have years, years
of,
you know, above $100, closer to $150
oil. What happens to the global economy
if that happens? How do we see it?
>> have global recession.
If there's a cessation of war, and yet
Iran Okay. So, this is Larry Fink, and
he's head of a company called BlackRock,
which is the largest asset manager in
the world. They control trillions and
trillions of dollars. And what he's
saying is he's He's being interviewed by
the BBC. What he's saying is we can't
stop this war now because
if we stop this war now, that means that
the price of oil will be too high for
many, many years. The Iranians will
control the Strait of Hormuz, and
therefore we must
fight this war to the end.
What he doesn't address is, "Well, if
you didn't start this war in the first
place, you wouldn't have this problem."
Because the Iranians would not would
have no pretext to close off the Strait
of Hormuz.
And the global economy would have been
fine.
But what he's saying But what he's
saying is like, "Oh, don't worry about
that.
Uh the problem is like is the war has
started, and therefore we must fight to
the end." Okay?
Okay. So, this is a drone launched by
a Iranian proxy in Iraq
flying over an American base.
And as you can see, there's nothing
stopping it, okay? It is flying over
this American base. It's It's being
remote controlled. It spots two American
helicopters, and it destroys one of
them. Okay?
Meaning that you have all these American
bases throughout the Middle East,
and they are vulnerable. They cannot be
protected against cheap drones.
So, from American's perspective,
this war
will either bankrupt the Americans,
or this war will be lost, okay? But it's
very hard to fight this war
against a determined enemy.
So, what I want to do now is
examine how this war will turn out,
okay? So, [snorts]
um I've said this many times, but
Americans are losing this war.
And the main reason is the problem of
hubris.
>> [snorts]
>> And so, I want to
examine closely what this means
strategically, what this means on the
battlefield, okay? So, war is fought
across
four dimensions.
All right?
There is the narrative dimension,
meaning global opinion, how history will
perceive this war.
There is the political dimension,
meaning
how your allies
perceive this war, how your domestic
base perceive this war. There's the
economic
and then there's the military.
If you If we examine this war closely,
the Iranians are fighting a very
different war
from the Americans.
What Americans are doing is basically
they are shifting the narrative,
political sphere, and economic sphere to
fit their economic strategy, okay? Their
economic strategy is decapitation,
which forces surrender,
right? So, what they want to do is they
want to knock destroy the Iranian
leadership, destroy the Iranian economy
to force a surrender, in which case the
Americans can dictate terms. That is
their strategy, and that's about it.
And they are forcing the narrative
space, the political space, and the
economic space to conform to the
military strategy,
meaning that they expect the allies,
NATO, they expect the media, they expect
the economy to support their strategy.
So, for example,
in the political space, Donald Trump has
ordered NATO
to come and open up the Strait of
Hormuz,
okay? And also,
Donald Trump refuses to announce the
fact that this war is very unpopular
back in America. In the economic space,
what Americans are trying to do is keep
the price of oil low so it does not
disrupt the global economy, and they do
that, of course, by unsanctioning
Russian and Iranian oil, which benefits
the Russian and Iranian economies.
Okay? And in the
narrative space, they're basically
trying to tell the media to
follow the party line. Donald Trump has
threatened
journalists that if you do not report
this war is going well, then I might put
you in prison.
All right? So, this is the American
strategy,
forcing the narrative, political, and
economic spheres to conform to military
strategy.
The Iranians have a different approach.
The Iranians are using the military in
order to impact the economic, political,
and narrative spheres.
All right? It's completely reverse.
Um so, the military strategy is
calculated in a certain way to
um benefit the Iranian economy, okay?
So, what I mean by that is
that the military is strategically
control the Strait of Hormuz so that
Chinese ships can pass, right? Because
Chinese ships are the main buyer of
Iranian oil.
Also,
if you are
um if you're willing to play ball like
Japan or Qatar or Oman, they will also
let your ships pass, okay?
So, this is being strategic.
Politically,
um the Iranians are trying to split the
Gulf states, right? They know that Saudi
Arabia and UAE are committed to regime
change in Iran, but they know that
Qatar, Bahrain I'm sorry Sorry, not
Bahrain. Qatar and Oman are on the other
side, okay? So, so they're they're
trying to gain as much political
leverage as possible within the GCC. And
the narrative is they're trying to shape
global opinion and trying to um
make everyone believe that they are on
are on the right side of history. And
most people believe that. In fact, you
have a lot of Americans who are rooting
for the Iranians to win. All right? So,
this is a very different These are two
um very different strategies. All right.
So, let's talk about this the advantages
and disadvantages of both strategies.
Okay. So, from the American perspective,
the fact that you have this have this
approach of making the world conform to
your military strategy basically means
that you lack
what we call reflection, okay?
>> [snorts]
>> Meaning that you're not able to sit down
with your strategists and discuss how
how this war is going and how to make
changes.
But the Iranians are able to do so
because the military has to conform to
the economic, political, and narrative
strategies, okay?
Second is
flexibility.
And what I mean by that is
the American strategy If it's not going
well for Americans, they lack the
capacity to reflect and make changes, so
what they do is they double down.
Okay? They accelerate the process
of bombing in Iran, even though it's
probably not going getting them
anywhere.
Also, much more importantly, the
Americans will choose much more
self-destructive, desperate strategies,
such as sending ground troops. It is
possible by this weekend ground troops
will be sent into Iran, which most
military analysts believe to be
uh either counterproductive or suicidal,
okay?
The um Iranians, on the other hand, can
adapt their military to military
strategy to the economic and political
realities, okay? So, for example, what
they're doing now is they're charging
tolls
um to cross the Strait of Hormuz, okay?
And the third difference is the idea of
resilience.
So, in other words, if you make the
world and America conform to your
military strategy, they won't support
you. That means that if you're losing
troops
and you're losing equipment, it is very
hard to replenish,
resupply.
Whereas it could be opposite in Iran,
where because they are winning popular
opinion, because their economy is
becoming stronger in this process,
because they're winning more popular
allies, they can actually draw on more
support from their population, and they
can also recruit foreign fighters and
foreign support, foreign sympathy for
their cause, okay? So, for these
reasons,
I believe that America is losing this
war and that ultimately this war will be
lost.
When this will happen, we don't know,
because America is an empire and they
can they can actually drag this on for
at least 20 years. All right? Okay.
So, now that we've discussed why America
will probably lose this war, I want to
now shift our focus to discuss
how the world will change because of
this war. What does the end of this war
look like? And to do that,
what's really important is to go back to
our model of how the world works, okay?
So, remember last week we discussed um
the structure of the world, and at the
very core is the empire.
Because the empire provides the muscle,
the military might, to shape the
contours of reality, okay?
And then, with the empire, you have the
fi- the finance,
okay? Finance includes um
City of London, Wall Street, Bank of
International Settlements,
and asset managers, and they are the
game masters, okay?
Okay? The empire is the muscle, but the
finance are the ones who actually set
the game.
And then, this creates the global
economy,
which is based on the US dollar, right?
But you can't actually
have people believing that this is the
way the game is structured, because then
people won't want to play the game. So,
what you do is you create additional
layer of multilateral organizations,
what the Americans like to call the
rules-based international order,
including the UN and the WTO,
okay? And other organizations.
But this is But this makes people
believe
that um the way the world is structured
is fair, open, and transparent, and you
hide the finance and the empire behind
multilateral organizations, okay?
And then, to justify
um
this system, you have the uh culture,
education,
and media, which then creates the
different legal infrastructure of
different nations and the values as
well, yeah? So, this is how the world is
organized. We also discussed how there
are these organizations that are above
the nation-state, that are above the
system, in order to benefit from the
system, to keep it going, but but to
extract rent from it. And these include
um intelligence,
crime,
and science.
We also discuss how
the organizing
uh
forces behind intelligence, crime, and
science
um are transnational capital,
uh secret societies,
as well as elite families.
And we discuss how they are bound
together by a concept called the occult,
which we'll study later on, okay? But
the idea of the occult, okay? So, this
is the structure of the world. Now, once
this world is created, [clears throat]
what you need to understand is that the
people in different spheres
who benefit from the system, first and
foremost, their interest is maintaining
that status quo. Okay?
So, their interest is in maintaining the
status quo.
All right? So, basically, they want the
system to continue.
The problem with the system is at the
core is an empire that will probably
lose the war in Iraq.
And this creates a problem because if
the empire falls, then it's possible
this entire edifice falls as well.
So, the only solution
is to replace the empire, the American
empire, with another empire. All right?
That is able to to provide the muscle
for this system. And this empire, I've
argued in the past, is of course Israel.
And this is what we call Pax Judaica.
Okay?
So,
on the surface, it seems like this war
is one between the United States and
Iran. But in reality, what this war
really is about is a war between the
United States and Israel, where the
American empire has become corrupt,
incompetent, and arrogant. And so, now
Israel sees an opportunity to replace
the American empire in the system. And
it's something that eventually every
aspect of the system will agree to do.
All right? So, the main outcome of this
war, when it ends,
is that Israel will will replace America
in the Middle East.
Okay? All right.
So, let me first discuss
why the American empire is falling,
okay? And the main reason is the idea
something called the military
industrial
complex.
So,
for most of its history, America did not
have a professional army. Why? Because
the founding fathers and most American
citizens believed that if there's if
there's a standing army if if there's a
professional army, that's a direct
threat to the liberty
of the Americans, okay? Because the
Americans fought a war, the
Revolutionary War, to get rid of of the
professional army that was the British.
Okay? So, Americans do not like a
professional army. But in order to fight
World War I and World War II, they
didn't have a choice but to create a
standing army.
The problem is that after America won
World War II, the apparatus stayed.
And the apparatus wanted to maintain the
status quo. Meaning, they wanted access
to unlimited government funds.
So, this led to the Cold War.
And the Cold War was a justification
for the MIC, the military industrial
complex,
to get as much government funding as
possible. And the blue, as you can see,
is government expenditures.
Okay? We can understand why they spent
all this money
in World War II because they were
fighting a war to save America and to
save the world. But as you can see, uh
even though it dropped drastically at
the end of the war, starting with the
Cold War, you have this uptick, okay?
And then you have the Vietnam War.
And then,
um after America won the Cold War, you
saw this massive uptick in this thing
called the War on Terror.
So, the military industrial complex is
always looking to start wars
in order to justify its existence. So,
there's a very famous journalist named
Julian Assange.
And he said this about America.
The point
is not to have successful wars. The
point is not to win wars. The point is
to have never-ending wars, which allows
the military industrial complex to
transfer American taxpayer money
to a transnational elite.
Okay? It's basically the point of wars
is for the military industrial complex
to steal as much money as possible from
America.
Okay?
Um America spends a lot of money
uh in its military, okay? America
accounts for 41%
of all global military spending.
Um who's next? China. China spends 8.2%.
Uh Russia, which is
America's main military enemy, only
spends 4.1%,
okay? Meaning that Russia spends 1/10
the amount of money that America spends.
And you think that, okay, well, this all
this means is that is that America is
invincible.
But what people don't recognize is the
level of corruption
within the American military.
The American military is probably the
most corrupt institution in the world by
far. Nobody even comes close, okay?
Um
September 10th,
uh 2001,
Donald Rumsfeld, who was the secretary
of defense for the Americans, uh he's
head of the Pentagon, and this is the
day before September 11th, the 9/11
attacks, he said that he he had a press
conference, he said that, "Look, we've
looked at the Pentagon books, okay?
We're trying to do an accounting of the
Pentagon military uh spending, and we
can't find $2 trillion. There's $2
trillion missing from the budget. It
went somewhere, we don't know where, but
it went somewhere, okay?"
All right. All right. So, this is a
um So, where does the money go? It goes
to private contractors, okay? These are
all private companies
that
make a lot of money off the
government, okay? So, look at look at
the Boeing company.
They had in 1 year
$20 billion.
Um
from the government. They They got $20
billion in contracts from the
government, okay?
To do so, they had to spend $16 million
in order to lobby Congress for
advertisements, for political campaigns.
And then they bribed This is This is a
bribe to politicians. They They spent $2
million, okay?
So, this is a really good business to be
in. You spend $2 million
uh to you you you give some bribe to
politicians, then you spend $16 million
um on campaigns, and then you make $20
billion, okay? This is extremely
profitable. The difference, of course,
is being picked up by the American
taxpayer.
The Boeing company is
um
doesn't It's not just a defense
contractor, but also makes civilian
airplanes. And for these past few years,
there's been quite a few cases of
civilian airplanes falling out of the
sky made by Boeing, okay? So, for
example, the Boeing 737 Max, okay? There
was a recall because there were some
engineering issues with the plane. Now,
there have been a couple of
whistleblowers who've come out and tried
to say that Boeing uh
is a corrupt company, and for whatever
reason, they they died, okay? They just
disappeared. We don't know why, but when
they were about to testify against
Boeing, they somehow died. All right? Um
this is a really interesting story that
shows you the level of corruption in the
Pentagon.
There is this woman who's a contractor
for the army,
and she stole $103 million.
Okay? That's a lot of money. $103
million. She stole it.
The army didn't know, and she kept on
stealing, and no one seemed to care in
the army.
But then the IRS
um this is the Internal Revenue Service.
They recognized that she was getting all
this money from somewhere, so they
investigated her and recognized, "Oh my
god, she's stealing from the army." So,
the IRS told the army, and that's when
the army recognized, "Oh, we have a
problem, okay?"
The fact that the army didn't notice
that she was stealing 103 million
dollars,
tells you
actually theft in the military is
probably a very common thing.
All right?
So,
ultimately, what this means is
that this corruption in the Pentagon is
not really sustainable.
Okay? So, let me discuss
um
why
this is a problem for America in Iraq,
okay? So, right now in America
is facing three major issues
um with this war in Iraq.
Uh the first major issue is the lack of
political will.
Meaning that this war is very unpopular
in America. Only 40% of the population
currently support this war, and as
things go on and on,
support will probably decrease.
Okay?
Um you need political will because you
need Americans to pay for this war.
Trump has asked for 200 billion dollars
to fund this war, and also it's possible
that Trump will call the national draft,
which I believe will happen.
Um
Okay? So, if Americans don't want to
support this war, it's very hard to get
them to pay for this war and to go fight
this war. Second problem is lack of
manufacturing capacity.
So, in other words, what this means is
that if you lose planes, if you spend
too many if you use too many bombs, you
cannot replenish it because you don't
have the factories to produce these
planes and
bombs quickly enough. Okay?
And so, if this war drags on too
long, then America will just run out of
bombs.
Now, and uh
third problem for America is
unwillingness
to sustain
casualties. Okay? And what this means is
that
Americans the American military is
afraid of reporting deaths, casualties,
which is weird because in a war,
soldiers die. That's just the reality of
war. But the Pentagon is afraid of
reporting too many deaths because of the
back of because of the fear political
backlash.
Okay?
So, these are three major problems for
the American military in Iraq. These are
the three major
constraints.
All right? So,
the Americans can't actually resolve
these issues. America will probably lose
this war,
in which case, this is gives opportunity
for Israel
to prove
to the world that it should be the
empire, okay? And if it proves it can be
the empire by showing that it does have
political will, it does have a it does
have it does have the manufacturing
capacity, but it has more Mossad, okay?
And it is much more strategic.
The last thing is that it is resilient,
meaning that it is willing to accept
casualties, okay? So, basically, the
idea here is the global elite, they need
an empire to provide the muscle, but the
empire must prove that it can serve the
needs of the global elite, okay? And it
And so, an empire must prove three
things.
First of all, it must prove
um
uh
unity,
it must prove
um it has the resources and the
capacity,
basically the capacity, okay?
And it must prove
um determination.
All right?
So, to understand this idea, let's just
do a thought experiment, all right?
Let's just say that we're venture
capitalists. We have billions of
dollars, we have trillions of dollars,
and we want to invest in a company,
okay? So, we're approached by two
companies.
We're approached by two companies.
Company A,
Company B, okay?
So, Company A comes to us and says that,
"Look, I have 100 companies,
and they're all profitable.
Okay? I don't have a business plan, but
I have lots and lots of resources, and a
lot of experience, and a lot of skill,
and so if I were to invest in another
company, I'm sure it'll make a lot of
money."
Okay?
All right. So, skills and experience.
That is Company A.
Company B is
these young guys,
and they failed, okay?
But they're like, "You know what? We're
going to put our heart and soul into
this enterprise.
We're going to work 16 hours a day,
every day for as long as it takes, and
we won't stop, okay? Even if this
company is successful, we're going to
keep on going because it's our passion.
And if this company fails, then we're
bankrupt. We might kill ourselves."
All right? So, if you are the venture
capitalist, you put your money in A, or
do you put your money in B?
Now, most people would put their money
in A because they think it is low risk.
But if you're a smart venture
capitalist, you put your money in B
because it's high reward.
Okay? So, Company A has already has 100
companies that are successful.
People in the company don't really care
if this new enterprise is successful or
not. Who cares? All right? I can afford
to lose, in which case, it's more likely
the Company A steals your money than
actually invest it properly. Whereas
Company B is going to be the opposite,
where this is their last chance.
If they take your money, they're going
to make sure that they grow it because
if they don't grow it, then they
themselves die.
Okay? So, you need
um
these things. You need unity,
capacity, and determination.
Do you understand that? And so, it What
What Israel is doing really is basically
auditioning to the world, "We are ready
to replace America. We are ready to be
the new empire." Okay? All right.
So, let's look at what's happening.
Um America has its MIC, and so the MIC,
military-industrial complex, what
they're good at doing is producing very
expensive weapon systems. But
unfortunately, when you actually put
these weapon systems into war, doesn't
really do anything, okay? So, this is
the Patriot missile system that's
supposed to
that's supposed to protect the GCC and
Israel and American military bases from
uh Iranian drones and missiles. Guess
what, guys?
Doesn't really work, okay?
In fact, uh as you can see from the
video,
the Iranians can basically fly drones
anywhere in the Middle East, and
Americans can't really stop them.
All right? So, this is billions of
dollars doesn't really do anything.
This is called the F-35.
The F-35 is the most advanced
fighter jet in the whole world. It has
stealth technology, meaning you can't
actually lock onto it using radar.
This costs 100 million dollars each. It
took 26 years to develop. So, you would
think, "Wow, it took 26 years, so this
must be really, really good." No, it
took 26 years because the MIC is really
corrupt, and they want to steal as much
money as possible, okay? And in this
war, the Iranians have already shot down
at least one of these jets.
Okay? This is not supposed to happen.
You're not supposed to be able to shoot
these things down. The Iranians have
shot it down using very low radar.
Again, these things, they're not
designed to win wars, they're designed
to steal as much money as as possible
from American taxpayer, okay? The last
example is the Gerald Ford. This ship
costs 13 billion dollars.
It costs 13 billion dollars. The annual
defense budget for the Iranians is 10
billion dollars.
It goes into the war theater, and 3
weeks afterwards, it has to run away,
okay?
And in fact, the Americans say, "Oh, the
Gerald Ford, this is the most advanced
supercarrier in the world. It's probably
going to be
down for repairs next 2 years."
And there's argument as to what
happened, okay? There are three
different possibilities. The first
possibility is that um
there was an accident in the laundry
room, and there was a fire, and this
fire spread throughout the carrier,
okay?
Which means that actually, the carrier
is not very resilient, okay? So, that's
one possibility, and that's what the
official
story is. But there are also others who
say that the Iranians hit the ship with
a missile, and so the Gerald Ford can't
protect itself from Iranian missiles, so
it ran away, okay? The third
possibility, the third explanation is
the Pentagon recognized that there are
severe limitations
of the Gerald Ford in actual combat
operations.
Um its radar, its guidance system are
all very limited, so the Pentagon
withdrew the Gerald Ford because it was
actually useless in war.
All right? Whichever story is true, it
doesn't paint a good picture of the
American military. $13 billion.
And this does nothing, okay? It's just a
white elephant.
The reason
And also,
um this is Iwo Jima. And this
came
in World War II in the Pacific Theater
when the Americans were fighting the
Japanese. And this is the height of
American military glory, okay? It took
about 6,000
The Americans lost 6,000 Marines in
taking this island.
And that's the sacrifice you need in
order to win wars. You're going to lose
a lot soldiers. And Americans are proud
that um they were willing to make the
sacrifice necessary to win the war. The
problem is
Americans are not going to willing to
sustain casualties, okay? So, the
Americans sent about 5,000, around 5,000
Marines to um Iran hoping that 5,000
Marines will be enough to win this war,
okay? But it just shows you the
Americans have no strategy to win this
war, and they want they don't want to
want to make the necessary sacrifices to
win this war. They want to win this war
as quickly and as cheaply as possible,
okay?
The issue The Israelis um are different,
okay? This is Gaza.
And we all know that what Gaza did was
terrible. But again, if you are
auditioning to an empire,
Gaza is proof of concept, okay? Meaning,
it's showing the global elite, "Look,
we're willing to do what it takes to win
this war and defend the empire."
Okay?
So, this was a tremendous tragedy, and
this and it's all war crimes, okay? And
the entire world is aghast. But if you
look at Israeli public opinion,
82%
support
expelling all Palestinians from Gaza,
okay? 66% believe
Amalek exists today. Amalek exists like
Israel has this great enemy that it must
defeat.
All right? So, 66% of Israelis believe
that this war against Gaza is is a war
for the very existence of Israel. Okay?
This is unity.
This is determination.
Americans don't have this. Most
Americans oppose what Israel is doing in
Gaza.
But what Israel But Israelis themselves
support what's going on, okay? So,
there's unity.
All right?
All right. So, um
in 2024, there was a famous Lebanon
pager attack, okay? Meaning that
um Israelis were able to implant bombs
into pagers that went to Hezbollah
members, and then it blew up, okay?
And maybe
um
from a military perspective,
it didn't accomplish that much. From a
psychological But from a psycho
psychological perspective, it
accomplished a lot, okay? It scared the
living hell out of Hezbollah. It made
them paranoid, and also made the world
respect Israel more. And Israel spent
$275 million to
to
uh conduct this operation. That took
decades to implement, okay?
And you're like, "Okay, why is Israel
telling us this?" Because again, Israel
is auditioning to be the new empire.
It's telling the global elite, "Look,
not only will we
fight this war for you. Not only will we
be your muscle, but we'll do it cheaply,
man. Not billions of dollars, millions
of dollars."
Um
This is ISIS.
ISIS is Islamic State, okay? And this is
considered as a terrorist organization,
these Sunni uh extremists who go around
and beheading people, all right? Now,
this is from the New York Times, and the
yellow tells you areas in which they
operate. And as you can see, it's really
across the Middle East. And the red are
um
incidents
of attacks directed by ISIS, okay? Now,
something that's really funny about all
this is
ISIS attacks everywhere in the Middle
East except for one country. And that
country is
Israel. Okay? Really funny how you have
these Muslim extremists going around
committing all sorts of atrocities
everywhere in the Middle East except
Israel.
And so, that's why a lot of people
believe that Islamic State is actually
creation of Mossad.
But again,
Israel is happy
for the world to know this because
again, Israel is auditioning to be the
new empire. And what Israel is saying
is, "We don't have to use the American
strategy of just bombing everyone to
death, okay? That's expensive, that's
brutal, and it's not very strategic. We
can use Mossad to infiltrate groups and
use these groups against the combatants,
their neighbors. Isn't that much more
efficient? Isn't that much more
effective, okay? So, what uh Israel is
saying is, "We are much better at
controlling the Middle East than the
Americans. So, let us control the Middle
East
using our strategies."
Okay?
Um this is a story of a Mossad agent
who was disguised as an ISIS preacher,
okay? And this happens a lot. There are
lots of stories where you have these
ISIS commanders or agents, and they And
when you arrest them, you discover,
"Okay, actually they're actually Mossad,
okay?" So, ISIS is basically a Mossad
operation.
All right.
So,
the main story here is, okay,
if you look at history, the relationship
between Israel and America is actually
pretty simple. Israel
is the pitbull
for America.
The problem with empire as it grows old
is it doesn't want to do bad things,
okay? It wants to feel good about
itself. Therefore, it subcontracts the
violence, the murder,
the genocide to different people, okay?
To mercenaries, Israelis in
um the Middle East. And this is a
pattern throughout human history. So,
the Romans started out as mercenaries
for the Etruscans in Italy. The Aztecs
started out as mercenaries for the
Colhua Mexica in Mexico. The Greeks
Persians, okay? The Mongols started out
as mercenaries for the Chinese. The Qin
started out as mercenaries for the
Sumerians. The Mamluks Mamluks started
out as mercenaries for the Ayyubid
dynasty in Egypt. In every instance,
what happened is the mercenaries
eventually got to the point where, "We
are the ones killing ourselves for this
empire. The empire is corrupt, decadent,
and weak. Why don't we just take it
over?"
And they did, okay? We're seeing a
similar situation play out today in the
Middle East where Israel was created by
the British and Americans to be the to
to be their pitbull, to be their um
aircraft carrier in the Middle East to
create as much instability as possible
so that the Americans and the British
could control the oil supply in the
Middle East. And this has gone for
decades, and now the Israelis are like,
"Wait a minute here. We're the ones
doing all the work. We're the ones
making all the sacrifices. We're the
ones that are getting all the hate in
this world. So, why shouldn't we be the
empire now? America's useless."
Okay?
All right. So, this is a pattern
throughout human
history. And
so, we're going to look at what this
means, okay?
So, Israel has something called the
Greater Israel project.
And this is what
um extremists in Israel believe. They
believe that God in the Bible promised
the entire Middle East to the
uh
Jewish people, okay? Extending from the
Nile in Egypt all the way to the
Euphrates
in
uh Iraq, okay? And it also encompasses
Saudi Arabia,
Jordan, Lebanon, Syria, and parts of of
Turkey as well, okay? Now, something
really funny about this map is this.
Iran, Persia
is not a part of the Greater Israel
project.
So, then you ask yourself, "Wait a
minute here. If Iran isn't a part of the
Greater Israel project,
then [snorts] why is Israel going to war
with Iran?"
Well, the reason why is if they want all
this territory,
their main enemy is not Syria, that's
been destroyed. It's not Iraq, that's
been destroyed. It's not Saudi Arabia,
it's too weak. Not Jordan, it's too
weak. Not Egypt, it's too weak. Not
Lebanon, it's not it's too weak, okay?
Their main enemy is
the American empire. Okay? In the
Greater Israel project, the main it's
the Americans that control
the land of Greater Israel, the Middle
East.
These are American bases. So, in other
words, you use this war against Iran to
destroy
the American empire. How? By forcing the
American empire
to go [music and singing] and invade
Iraq.
And when this happens, America will be
too overextended.
And then they'll be forced to retreat
from the Middle East.
Okay?
And so,
eventually America will be defeated.
America will be forced to retreat from
the Middle East. And that will leave two
regional powers, okay? Iran and Israel.
And again, because of the greater Israel
project, the Israelis have no problem
with this. Persia is again not part of
the greater Israel project. The Israelis
don't really care if Iran is still
standing. They want Iran to be
as weakened as possible, okay? But they
really don't care they really don't need
to defeat Iran to achieve the biblical
prophecy. But they do need to defeat the
Americans, all right? The Americans are
in the way. All right. [snorts]
Okay.
So,
what does the greater Israel project
mean? Well, it means control of the
world the world's oil, basically. 20% of
the world's oil. So, these are the gas
fields. The yellow are the gas fields
of the Middle East, all right? And the
blue
are the trade routes. So, you can see
how Israel is at the very center of all
this wealth.
Right? They have the logistics, they
have the technology. It makes sense for
them to take control of all these
resources and then start shipping these
resources to Europe as well as to East
Asia, China, South Korea, and Japan.
Okay?
So, that's what the Pax Judaica will
look like. It will be a trade network
controlling all the resources
of the Middle East and then shipping off
to the rest of the world.
All right.
>> [clears throat]
>> Then you have data centers, okay?
So, Israel has the most data centers in
the Middle East. And then Saudi Arabia
has 36.
Uh UAE has 34, okay? So, these three
places are competing
against each other for AI dominance.
Why is AI important? Because it allows
you to create a surveillance state.
Surveillance is is what you need for an
empire.
Right? You need to control the
population.
All right. Now,
the problem with Saudi Arabia and UAE is
for them to build their data centers,
they need to import
foreign expertise. They themselves do
not have the human capital to build
these data centers and to run these data
centers. On the other hand, Israel does,
okay? Israel has the best universities
in the Middle East. It has the best IT
talent in the Middle East. It has It has
the best human capital. Therefore, it
makes perfect sense for Israel to just
absorb
the entire AI network of the Middle East
and become the main epicenter of AI
surveillance in the Middle East, okay?
Which will become the backbone of Pax
Judaica.
One more.
Um
So, what does Pax Judaica look like?
It's really the India-Middle East trade
corridor, okay?
All right. So, look look at this map
where
uh for India to get to Europe, it has to
go through
Israel.
Okay?
So, this is what Pax Judaica will look
like. Basically, a the map trade
corridor that that will
unite the South Asian continent with
Europe, okay?
But not only that,
but the idea of this is also to connect
to Africa.
Right?
Because no other place is able to access
Africa.
Only Israel is.
And not only that, but it's also able to
access
Ukraine and Russia.
So, the idea is to take
Russia and Ukraine energy and food and
then
transport it into Africa.
That's combining the world. Okay? So,
Israel, because of its location, can
really be the epicenter of all global
trade.
All right. Now, let's look at um
Iran.
So, for the longest time, Iran did have
lots of resources oil oil resources. But
the Americans put sanctions
on this these oil exports.
This war has basically lifted all
sanctions, okay?
So, the Iranian economy
is now able
to
export its oil all across the world. So,
this is Trita Parsi and he is probably
America's foremost expert on Iran. And
he's talked to a lot of people. And what
he's saying is basically
Iran now is able to produce oil,
transport it across the world, and then
get money for it, okay?
So, what the the conclusion he makes is
this.
Trump and Israel's war has ended up
delivering Iran de facto sanctions
relief.
Before the war, Iran was cut off from
the global economy. Because of this war,
Iran now is becoming embedded into the
global economy. It's the complete
opposite of the intention of this war.
And what this means is Iran is now less
incentivized to end the war.
Okay?
The more this war keeps on going, the
more Iran benefits economically.
All right. [snorts]
So, Iran, once this war ends, becomes
the epicenter of two major trade
networks.
Okay? The first is something called the
North-South transport corridor that
links Russia
Okay?
Um and
you and Iran together, okay?
And this will then allow Russia to
access India and Asia.
And allow Iran to access
Europe, okay? So, this is the
North-South corridor that's controlled
by Russia. But also,
you have, of course, the Belt and Road
Initiative. And guess what?
Iran
is also at the epicenter of this trade
network, okay? So, for China to access
Europe, it has to go through Iran. For
Europe to access China, it has to go
through Iran as well.
Okay?
So, this is what the new world will look
like after the war. You'll have two
regional powers, Israel and Iran.
And they will
have their own independent trade
networks.
And they will have their own access to
resources. So,
Israel will control the resources of the
Middle East.
And Iran will control the Strait of
Hormuz, okay? And with the Strait of
Hormuz, they can act like a toll, which
will feed the economy. They will be
helped by Russia Russia and China
because it is in Russia and China's best
interest to develop the infrastructure
of Iran to facilitate global trade.
Okay?
But then you're like, "Wait a minute
here. But Iran and Israel are enemies."
Okay.
So, this is a misunderstanding.
Ideologically, Iran and Israel are
enemies. But I want to teach you three
basic principles or rules of
geopolitics, okay?
And once you understand these rules,
it'll be much easier for you to
understand the new world that we're
going into. The first is this.
The strong respect each other and prey
on the weak, okay? Does that make sense,
right?
Why are the strong fighting each other?
Wouldn't it be easier for them to like
leave each other alone and go pick on
the weak?
It benefits everyone, right?
So, in this situation, right? You have
four You have um
different countries. You have GCC, you
have um Israel, you have the United
States,
you have um Iran.
Okay? So, you have these four different
players in this war. Right now, it's
essentially um Israel, GCC, and US
fighting against Iran.
But
if
Iran proves it is strong,
and Israel proves it's strong,
and GCC proves it's weak, the US proves
it's weak, guess what's going to happen?
Israel and Iran are going to get
together and say, "SCREW THESE GUYS.
LET'S JUST WORK TOGETHER, MAN."
OKAY, DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
Even though in the beginning it seems as
though
Israel, GCC, and US are allies against
Iran,
ultimately,
if if Iran is able to prove it's strong,
then Israel will abandon the GCC and the
United States.
And Israel will work with Iran to build
a new order in the Middle East. Because
that's the law of the jungle, okay? That
is what is in the best interest,
according to game theory, for Israel.
And the last
thing to understand is the weak do not
work well together. The weak must ally
with the strong for protection, okay?
So, what this means is the GCC is weak,
right? So, you look at
Saudi Arabia,
UAE,
>> [clears throat]
>> uh Bahrain,
Oman,
>> [snorts]
>> Kuwait,
Qatar, okay?
So, these are the six GCC countries.
They're all weak.
And you would think, you know what? If
they were to combine their resources and
fight together, THEY COULD PROBABLY beat
Israel or probably probably beat Iran.
The problem with this is weak players
don't work well together, okay? They're
weak because they're stupid.
They
are And so, what they do is rather than
seek to work together, what they do is
they seek to ally with stronger forces,
okay? So, right now, they're they're all
aligned with the United States and
Israel.
All right? Against Iran.
But as this war progresses and the US
falls, then what will happen is that
they must either choose Israel or Iran.
And what's going to happen is that you
might have some places, Qatar and Oman,
who choose, you know what? Screw this.
We're going to join Iran. And then you
have Saudi Arabia and UAE who are like,
okay, let's join Israel, okay?
But the GCC, regardless of what happens,
will no longer be a major geopolitical
factor in the Middle East anymore. A lot
of them will be destroyed because of
this war.
All right? So, according to game theory,
this is what the world should look like
after the war ends. But again, this all
theory. Okay? This is a class
focused on intellectual speculation.
It's meant to be fun. It's meant to to
make us more curious about the world.
It's supposed to heighten our critical
thinking skills. This is not meant to be
prophecy, okay?
I'm not saying this must happen. I'm
saying this might happen for these
reasons. And if they do happen, because
oh
if they do happen, then this provides us
a good framework to understand our
reasoning better, okay? If it doesn't
work out this way, it's fine because
we'll just go back and analyze what what
what went wrong better, okay? What's
really important is not to set a
judgment. What's really important is to
keep our minds open and be open to the
possibility of
um different outcomes. All right?
Okay, any questions, guys?
Um if Israel really like defeated
America, what will
>> no, no. I didn't say Israel will defeat
America. I never said that. Okay?
>> Well, Israel might
>> no. Let's be clear about language. I did
not say Israel will fight America. What
I said is Israel is auditioning to
replace America. Israel is trying to
prove to global elite, I'm strong enough
to replace America when America leaves
the Middle East. You understand? Yeah.
Okay? Let's be clear about language.
Okay? Yes?
Like um what will like Israel try to
prove that it's stronger than America?
And
I'm curious like what the next step
Israel will take if like it's trying to
show that it's strong.
Okay. [clears throat]
All right.
So,
look,
Israel doesn't have to do anything
different. Israel is determined to win
this war, right? That's all it has to
do. I mean, Israel is determined to win
this war
and the United States is not determined
to win this war. The United States
doesn't even know what it's doing, okay?
All right? So, what's important, okay?
What's really important
is to go back to our analysis
of
Oh, sorry. Yeah, yeah, like um this is
All right.
Okay. Let's let's let's to our analysis,
okay? Remember,
Iranian Empire.
Iranian Empire, okay?
And you have the finance, the game
masters.
And then you have um the global economy.
Okay. All right.
So, these are the three main players.
And again, this is a really important
idea to understand.
All these players are interested in
maintaining the status quo.
Eventually, as this war progresses,
they're going to recognize that America
is actually a problem. The American
Empire is not a good thing. It's not a
benefit to us. It's an it's a problem
for us. And so, we need to replace the
American Empire.
Right? And who's the only alternative?
Israel.
So, we need to transition from
America to Israel if we are to maintain
the system.
Then they'll recognize that, okay,
the problem though is America will not
go away.
Empires don't surrender power willingly.
And so, we need to create a situation
which America is forced out of the
Middle East.
Now, Iran cannot defeat America on the
battlefield. America can drag this thing
on for at least 20 years. But we don't
we don't want to wait 20 years because
we'll lose a lot of money in the
process. And there's no point in waiting
20 years.
So, we need to force America out of the
Middle East. So, if we cannot if we
cannot defeat America, sorry, sorry. If
Iran cannot defeat America
on the battlefield, what we need to do
is cause America to implode.
We need to cause a collapse in America.
And how do you do that? The economy.
If I crash the stock market,
if I cause oil to go way up,
if I cause civil discontent in America,
this will cause a civil war in America.
And then the American military has no
choice but to retreat back into America,
okay? And then Israel will naturally
take over from America.
And this is something we'll discuss next
class, okay? The strategy for how to
destroy the American Empire and replace
it with Israel.
All right? Okay, does that make sense?
Okay, any more questions, guys?
Okay, great. So, I will see you next
week, okay?